good morning
thanks for stopping by
um
the keynote is full of a lot of
mind-blowing demos
i enjoy it every time
what is easy to forget
in the face of all of that is that
underneath when you do data science or
analytics there's actually some
relatively simple concepts
so we're going to look at it from a
completely different angle for this hour
there will be no math
no computers even
and the goal is just to take these
concepts and to make them really
concrete get them in your hands so even
if you're completely new to it you'll at
least walk out with a basic idea of how
it all fits together
so we're going to take a little journey
and this is a map we'll be referring to
it
we start out the beginning of any
data-driven project is getting data or
getting more data
data
is just numbers and names
uh so with numbers things that we can
measure
temperature you know 38.3 degrees
or count something the number of people
in this room
and there's lots of other things you can
measure like the intensity of sound at
an instant or the brightness of a pixel
all these things you can put numbers on
you can add them subtract them divide
them they behave like numbers
and then the other type of thing you can
do are names or
categories or types
so these are things like a breed of a
dog
a type of a hot drink
the name on an aircraft or on a droid
there are things that if you change them
a little bit
you could be pointing to something
completely different
so these are two fundamentally different
types of data
now
it's uh to make things extra tricky
there are names that actually look like
numbers
so if you take your phone number
and then you just increase it by one and
someone calls that if it were a number
you would expect that to do something
close like ring the person next to you
but this could ring someone on the other
side of the country this is just a
pointer an identifier and there's
actually quite a few numbers that look
like that so if you have zip codes or
social security numbers or credit card
numbers
these are actually
names if you try to start adding and
subtracting them funny things will
happen
similarly there are names that look like
numbers
or names that can be turned into numbers
so these are
things that have a well-defined order
and approximately the same spacing in
between
first place second place third place
small medium large
so these are things that you can
actually pretty easily translate into
numbers and you can do things like uh
add and subtract them if you're careful
about it
so this process of taking names and
numbers
measuring and collecting and storing and
searching and transforming them this we
refer to sometimes as data engineering
it is a
very uh intense discipline requires a
lot of careful thought requires a lot of
software there's a whole collection of
microsoft tools listed over on the right
for doing these tasks
i'm not going to talk about them in this
talk they will probably come up quite a
bit in the other talks that you visit
this week i encourage you to listen and
learn all you can about them they're
very cool
we're going to set them aside for now
similarly there is a
data science process that matches this
roadmap that we're going to cover very
closely that emphasizes these individual
tools
tutorials on how to use them
there will be a link to it that will go
out with these slides at the end of the
talk
i encourage you to check that out as
well
once we have data the next step is to
ask a sharp question
now a sharp question is one that has to
be answered with a name or a number
a vague question on the other hand
doesn't necessarily have to
to keep this distinction straight in my
head i think of a genie
who
you can ask him questions
he's bound to give an accurate answer
but
he's mischievous
and he'll give the least helpful answer
that he possibly can
so if you ask a question like how can i
increase my profits the genie might say
work harder
motivate your employees outplay your
competitors
all great advice
none of it is helpful in making an
immediate decision
however if you were to ask a question
such as how many times will the feature
that i built get used by a new user
that cannot be answered except with a
number giving you exactly the
information you want
that's the type of question we have to
ask our data to get good
answers back
so we've come up with a sharp question
in this case what will the stock price
of my company be next week it would be
really useful if we knew that
we can gather a bunch of data that's
relevant such as our history of sales in
different regions information about our
competitors
um our
products uh how often they're used in
the first month and in the first quarter
in the first year by different users
and then other information perhaps
economic information throughout the rest
of the world
what we absolutely need
to be able to answer this question is
also historical information about the
stock price
so the question that we're trying to
answer
we need examples of answers to that
question from the past
that's how machine learning works it
just looks for what relationship have
have these had in the past
then in the future when we get all this
other information about sales and
competitors and stock markets then we
can guess
based on that relationship what will our
stock price be
that's called our target variable our
target data
it's not uncommon to get a data set and
then to ask a question that doesn't have
you don't have target data for
in which case you go back to the
beginning and gather more data
the next step
is to take all that data and to put it
into a table
this merits its own stop on our journey
because it's not as straightforward as
you would expect
so for our question
what will our stock price be next week
we go and measure stock prices
historically and we get the closing
price at the end of every day
this determines
the form our table takes we have one
example of our target variable per day
we want to transform all of our other
variables so we have one value per day
every row on this table will have
exactly one instance of our target
variable
now to do this there are var a variety
of tricks we can do
sometimes we have to aggregate so let's
say we would like to know the total
number of users we have on any given day
but the form this data takes in our
database is a list of usernames and the
list of the dates that they joined
in order to know how many users we have
today we have to go back through and add
them up
aggregation
another common one is distribution
so if i want to include information
about my last month's sales
that'll be true throughout this whole
month every single row that's relevant
to this month will have the same number
there i have to take it and distribute
it throughout the table
another thing we can do is computation
so if i want to include the number of
days since a product release
but
in my database what i have stored is the
date
and name
of each product when it was released
then i have to go and do some simple
calculation i have to find what's the
most recent product release and subtract
to get the number of days
there are some things that you just want
to go out and measure
you can do that bring in new sources of
data for instance the dow jones
industrial average on each of those days
and then some things you may not have
access to directly
you can estimate
if you have a way to make a reasonable
guess
then that's actually better than nothing
at all so you can fill the table in with
your reasonable guesses where you lack
hard data
and as a last resort you can actually
leave blanks
there are ways to deal with that as
we'll see in just a couple of minutes
so once you have your data in a table
you have nice it's called a rectangular
format you have one row for each of your
target variables you're ready to move on
to the next step
we want to check our data for quality
if you've ever worked with real data
it's it's really pretty messy it's
gathered by real people like you and me
that
some of us are more careful than others
some of us see the world a little
differently than others and that gets
reflected in the data
so here's an example data set
to show what i mean
now the first thing to do when presented
with a new data set i like to go through
each of the columns and just make sure i
understand what's there
so here we have id looks like some kind
of identification number
a first and last name
a birth year
the individual's height the place they
were born
whether or not their identity is secret
information about whether they can fly
their alignment
it looks by looking at the data it's
like whether they're good or bad
and whether or not they wear a cape
so in this data set we can see it's nice
and rectangular and by convention unless
you're told anything else the target
variable is the very last column often
so this data set will help us in the
future know whether or not someone wears
a cape
once we know all this other information
about them
now before we can use this um
we need to do some cleaning so the
identification numbers they all look
like nice four-digit ids no obvious
repetitions nothing badly formatted
same with the first and last names they
all look like very nice plausible first
and last names
when we get to birth year though
it looks like this was maybe something
that was manually entered
and we can see that there are stray
punctuation lots of different formats
some people use quotes
we also have a 2286 bc which is a valid
date but uh is difficult to interpret
for a computer as a number
in order to clean this up
kind of puree this and make baby food
out of it for the computer we need to
get a uniform representation
so we go through
and one way or another using the tool of
your choice
make a nice uniform representation we
even take our 2287 bc and turn it into a
nice negative integer
now the computer can add and subtract
these and do whatever it wants to do
with numbers to learn about them
now height poses a different problem
these are all nicely formatted no errors
or inconsistencies
but it's kind of a quirky format so
unless the computer automatically knows
how to interpret this it'll just
interpret it as a string and it won't
know that six foot one is any closer to
six foot zero than it is to four foot
zero
so we just translate it into inches
now it's a nice number computer can add
and subtract and do what it does with
numbers
birth places look good
all one of them is unknown but that's a
perfectly okay thing to put
this identity is secret now this is
confusing this is a really common thing
some of them are blank
some of them say n a one says missing
it's not at all obvious what that means
when you're dealing with data it's a
really common experience to be given
something like this and to scratch your
head
what you often have to do is look for
documentation what do these fields mean
these uh entries in these fields
uh often track down the person who
collected the data and say hey what were
you thinking what what did this mean
sometimes you have to do some
research of your own to dig into it and
sometimes you just have to make an
educated guess
but the goal
is a nice clean uniform representation
so after doing one of those things
we get a nice yes and no all the way
down the column
similar for ken fly looks like this was
a free entry field lots of different
formattings and spelling some got number
grades some get qualitative assessments
we go through
and use our judgment and our research to
unify this as well
you can see this is a very
human intensive process to do this this
part there are
it's an unsolved problem to do all of
this automatically mostly because we use
a lot of what we know about the outside
world to make this happen
uh similarly with alignment you know we
wanted to go through and make this a
nice uniform representation and we're
successful and it just so happens
there's three levels when we're done uh
selena kyle doesn't really fit in the
good or the bad category so we put her
somewhere in the middle
and then finally with the target
variable as well go through nice clean
uniform representation
this is what it means to clean your data
to get it into a form so that
the machine learning algorithms with
their limitations
can process it well and make sense of it
now we have nice big clean rectangular
well formatted data
sometimes we have to do some additional
feature engineering it's called to
transform what's there to make it useful
so here's an example of some data
column zero
column one these are a couple of
features column two will be our target
variable
so
we would like to predict future values
of column two
given future values of column zero and
one
to understand if there's a relationship
here already sometimes it's a useful
exercise to plot your features against
your target variable
and so we'll go ahead and do that
and in this case on the right we've
plotted feature one on the left we've
plotted feature zero in both cases the
y-axis is our target variable
and we can see that this is really uh
not helpful
if you eyeball a line through each of
those clouds
it's flat
which means that if i tell you the value
of one of those features it doesn't help
you at all to tell me what the target
value probably is
and in fact uh when i build a model out
of it this coefficient of determination
says how good the model is at predicting
what's going to happen next
um one is perfect
zero is absolutely worthless we're very
close to zero
so we take one step back
and think about where our data came from
now i tell you that column zero
is the time in hours
that a subway train
leaves central square station in boston
and column one is time in hours since
midnight that that same train arrives at
the kendall square station the next stop
and that column two our target variable
is the max speed of that train in
kilometers per hour
now we know
that arrival time and departure time are
related to speed
so they must interact
the default thing to do whenever you
have any two variables and you know
there's an interaction you multiply them
together to get another variable that's
a very simplest type of feature
engineering we get this interaction term
so in this case let's go ahead and
create this multiplication
and plot it against our target variable
we do that in the right hand plot there
we can see that it's actually still not
helpful there's still a big blob and the
best line we can eyeball through it is
horizontal
and sure enough the coefficient of
determination is still really close to
zero
so
the default approach did not work on
this particular data
we take yet another step back
freshman physics
speed
is distance divided by time
elapsed time now the distance is going
to be the same in all these cases
because we have our two stops and
they're not going anywhere
the elapsed time we can actually compute
which is the arrival time minus the
departure time the difference between
the two
so they do interact
but not
in a multiplicative way they interact by
subtracting one from the other
so if we calculate this elapsed time and
create a new variable out of that and
plot it against our target variable we
see something very different we see this
green swoosh on the right and if you
eyeball a line through that
then if i tell you the difference
between feature zero and feature one you
can make a really good guess what that
peak speed was
this is an example of having to massage
your features to get them into a form
that's useful
machine learning algorithms don't do
this automatically
they each have their own quirks there
are certain types of relationships that
some are better at pulling out than
others
none are good at pulling out all the
possible relationships
so knowing something about where your
data came from and what it means can
help you do this beforehand
and then it just kind of gives your
algorithms a leg up
and sure enough the coefficient of
determination is now very close to one
point eight eight
now there's lots of other feature
engineering tricks some are specific to
the type of data that you use uh there
are a lot that are specific to images
some are specific to text as well
and then there are others that are
specific to the domain you're working in
whether you're in economics or
agriculture or sociology there are
relationships that people have observed
or hypothesized for a long time that
seem to hold up
that domain knowledge gives you a lot of
built-in clues about how to combine your
data to get something that's predictive
that's useful
now you've probably heard about deep
learning
the reason deep learning is exciting is
because it's an attempt to pull all
these relationships out automatically
to learn what they all are so we don't
have to know everything about the
problem
now there's still a gap there but it has
closed it somewhat
and that's why it gets so much hype
that's why it's able to do things that
machine learning hasn't been able to do
previously
i won't have time to cover it in this
talk if you would like to
dive at a similar level into deep
learning i'll share a link to that at
the end as well
now
we have our features
next step is to answer the question
so a little detour here this is
this little um
this little number six
this is all of machine learning so we're
gonna do it real quick
add an overview there are just five
different questions that machine
learning can answer five types of
questions
so the first one is how much
or how many
the answer to this question will always
be a number
and these are questions posed in the
form of
you know what will the temperature be
next tuesday ah you know the answer is
38 degrees
what will my fourth quarter sales in
portugal b
there's a f there's a really uh concrete
numerical answer to that
these types of algorithms this family is
called regression and they're really
common we'll look at an example of one
in just a minute
the second family of categories
doesn't answer is an answer with a
number but with a name
so which category does this belong to
which label applies to this
for instance is this an image of a cat
or a dog
probably the most commonly asked
question in vision research
another is what aircraft is causing this
radar signature so i have my radar feed
i'm getting a blip i have a list of
things that could possibly be
which category does it belong to
or what's the topic of this news article
this family of machine learning
algorithms is called classification
it's very common actually to do
classification between just two classes
is this an example of a or not a is
there a dog in this picture or not a dog
and then there's also multi-class
classification i have a whole bunch of
topics which one or which ones apply to
this news article
our third family of machine learning
algorithms answer the question
how does this data naturally break down
into a bunch of groups
so you can imagine if i give you a bag
of m ms and say hey would you please
separate this out into some groups of
similar m ms
most of us would separate out the red
ones and the green ones and the yellow
ones and break them out by color
that's not the only way to do it
we could set them separate them out by
primary colors and all the other colors
we could measure them very carefully and
separate them out by weight or by sugar
content or by how perfect the m is
printed on them
there's lots of different ways they're
all valid
this is a hallmark of these type of
algorithms they are often called
clustering algorithms
often referred to as unsupervised
learning
but they make groups of things and
usually the groups are things that we
intuitively relate to
this is helpful in a lot of applications
you've probably experienced it if you're
a consumer of online streaming video
then your provider
has taken your viewing habits
and used that to lump you together with
a bunch of their other customers
and then
if there's a video that a lot of other
people in that lump have watched and
enjoyed that you haven't seen yet it
will probably be recommended to you as
hey you also might like
the fourth family
answers the question is this data point
weird
this is a really common question
when there is a problem
often
it's manifested by some kind of
weirdness something is unusual or
unexpected or out of spec
if you're driving in a car and you have
pressure sensors in your tires
it would be great to know if there's
some kind of really unusual reading
in those pressure sensors there might be
a problem
if you're doing internet security and
you get some really odd traffic
that might indicate that there's a
problem
and this is helpful when
computers can't go in and diagnose the
problem
but we have a human that can do that but
the human can only do so much so you
have the machine learning algorithm look
through millions or billions of examples
funnel that down to a few hundred that
it can then hand over to humans and have
a human in that loop
and you've probably experienced this all
of us our credit card companies are
monitoring our purchases every day
and asking this question about each one
of our purchases is this weird or are
the last few purchases weird
so when my credit card showed sudden
purchases of very expensive items from
the same vendor in different locations
that i've never purchased before
it sent up a flag that said this is
weird and it locked me out of my credit
card until i could call them and
straighten it out they were able to
invalidate those
this is able to solve me a lot of pain
in the long run and the credit card
company as
well so finally the
last family of algorithms a little bit
different flavor these are called
reinforcement learning algorithms
these are becoming more common in
robotics applications or automated
systems where a machine gets to decide
over and over again
what to do
these are usually small decisions
usually not with a terrible penalty for
getting it wrong so there's room for
trial and error and there are things
that have to happen a lot
so for instance in an automated
temperature control setting
the system has to decide whether to
raise or lower it on a regular basis or
if you have a robot vacuum at home it
has to decide every minute whether it
stays plugged in or goes out and vacuums
the living room again
now these are not all very low
consequence applications uh self-driving
cars for instance have to decide hey
there's a yellow light do i accelerate
or do i break
now they don't use an approach like this
because trial and error is not an
acceptable way to solve that problem
but that's the type of problem that this
solves
so
with that overview
we'll jump into an example
the goal of this is to show that these
things are not
scary
the concepts behind them are not
earth shattering
in this case
i have a setting a ring made for holding
a diamond that doesn't happen to have a
diamond in it
but it is built to hold a diamond that
weighs 1.35 carats
and i'd like to buy a diamond for it it
belonged to my grandmother i'd like to
restore it
so i go into a jewelry store and i'd
like to know hey how much will this cost
me to buy a 1.35 carat diamond
it turns out they don't have any
so
i decide huh machine learning data
science
i write down
the weight and the price of all of the
diamonds in the store
so for instance at the top of the list
there's a 1.01 carat diamond it's just
over 7 300
and so on down the list
then i take my pen and my paper
and i create a little number line
for the weight in carats and i see that
most of them fall between zero and two
so i size it appropriately
and i create another number line at a
right angle to that for the price
covers all of those values
and i start with the first diamond and i
eyeball a line that's about 1.01 carats
and i eyeball another line that's
horizontal that matches that links up
with it at about 73 66 dollars and right
where they meet i put a dot
so this is the
way you make a scatter plot with two
columns of data i repeat that for
everything all down the columns and when
i'm done i get a picture that looks like
this
now there's a secret in data science
that we don't talk about much
sometimes this is all you need to do
sometimes at this point when you have a
picture for instance if you have your
data plotted across the united states
the answer jumps out at you you can say
whoa my sales are way up in california
they're way down in idaho i know what i
need to do next
in this case you can say whoa the price
is a lot lower for lighter smaller
diamonds than it is for bigger diamonds
now we already knew that so that
actually doesn't answer our question so
we're going to keep going
when we look at those dots
you can see that there's an obvious
shape to them it's like a blurry line
that goes from
bottom to the top from left to right
and so we really carefully take our
sharpie and draw a line right through
the middle of it
this
step is actually really significant
it's easy to overlook because we do this
automatically in our brains all the time
but what we've done is we've taken the
actual
raw hard noisy data
and we've simplified it we've made a
cartoon version of it
and this lets us do a couple of things
it lets us answer questions really
concretely
it also lets us answer questions for
which we don't have any data
we don't have data points at every
weight along that x-axis
but we do have a line
so now what we can do
is say well i'm going to eyeball a line
up from
1.35 carats
and where it crosses
my diagonal line my model
i'm gonna eyeball a horizontal line over
to the price axis
and it hits right at about eight
thousand dollars
that is the answer to my question how
much will 1.35 carat diamond cost about
eight thousand dollars
this is
machine learning in action building a
model
making a prediction
it's not any more complicated than that
now
looking at this
another good follow-up question is well
okay
none of those dots lie exactly on that
line so i don't expect to pay exactly
eight thousand dollars but it will it be
8 000 plus or minus 50 plus or minus 5
000 like this will also be really
helpful when i'm deciding what to do
luckily we can solve this as well
we eyeball a nice fat envelope around
that line that captures most of our data
points it doesn't have to include all of
them
this we'll just call our confidence
interval
so we're pretty confident that our
future data will all lie in this region
because our past data all has
now we just look at where our 1.35 carat
line crosses that envelope on the bottom
and the top
and eyeball those lines over to the
price axis
and we see ah not only do i expect to
pay eight thousand dollars for my
diamond it will
very probably be
greater than
six thousand and less than about ten
thousand so somewhere in that range
now i know what i need to know to go out
and earn some money and prepare to make
this purchase
so i i want to take just a second to
give us all a collective pat on the back
so you have mentally just walked through
a full machine learning modeling process
and you were able to do it without any
computers
or any math there were no equations we
didn't even do multiplication here
um this is conceptually about as stiff
as it is
now
if instead of just weight and price we
also wanted to consider
the cut and the clarity and the color
and the number of inclusions in the
diamond then we start adding columns to
this
we can't draw it on a piece of paper
anymore and it's not as simple as
drawing a straight line you have to draw
a
funky multi-dimensional plane and it
gets really hard and your head starts to
hurt if you think about it too hard
luckily
math is the tool for doing that it can
find the very best high dimensional line
to fit through that and make a model
just like we would have made if we could
eyeball it
the other thing is if instead of about
15 diamonds we had 15 000 or 15 million
doing this by hand of course would take
a whole lot longer
that's where computers come in they're a
tool to let us do this with bigger and
bigger data sets
but what i want you to keep in mind is
what they're doing under the hood is not
magic
a common question when you're answering
a question with data is do i have enough
data how much do i really need to answer
it
and it all depends on what you want to
do with it
so when you look at your answer when you
look at your
line that we drew
if
we knew that our diamond was gonna cost
about eight thousand dollars plus or
minus
eight thousand dollars
that's actually not enough information
to make a good decision on
too fuzzy too blurry
here's an example a notional example of
what this image looks like when we don't
quite have enough information to
re
reconstitute it
there's something there but you can't
tell what just yet
you know you have barely enough data
when you can look at your answer and you
can kind of squint and you can say ah i
know what's going on just well enough to
make my decision
so in this case i see oh i can tell
that's a broad canal buildings on either
side beautiful sunset
i have decided i want to go there on
vacation
so that's when you have just barely
enough data
when you gather even more data that
actually allows you to make more and
finer grain decisions if you want
so now at this point you can stand back
and look and say oh
of the hotels on the left bank
that first one on the third floor has
fascinating architectural features
that's where i want to stay when i go
so with more data you can make
progressively finer decisions you can
ask finer questions that's what it buys
you
so we've answered our question
the next step
is to use the answer in some way
there's a lot of ways you can do this it
doesn't really matter how it all depends
on what you need and what your goal was
going into it but you can turn it into a
web service this is something that
microsoft's azure machine learning does
exceptionally well
you can simply use it to make a decision
or to set a price for your products
you can take this code and publish it
out on github
or you can write up a document sharing
your results build a dashboard
it doesn't matter
but
you have to do something with it or else
it'll disappear and it won't make any
difference to anyone except perhaps to
you
now there are a few big gaps gotchas
when you go to use your data
and
these are things that if you understand
them on a conceptual level it'll put you
ahead of
probably 90 of the general population
and even 50 of the technical population
these are things that are often
overlooked
so the first one
is that almost all machine learning
algorithms assume that the world doesn't
change
if i built a detailed model
of flight travel predicting the number
of passengers every day
10 years of data excellent performance
and i fielded that model on september 10
2001
on september 12 2001
i wouldn't expect it to behave very well
because on september 11th something
happened to change the system in a
pretty big way
relevant to what i was trying to predict
this is this can happen to any model
that we build any prediction that we
make
and the crazy part is the machine
learning algorithms are assuming the
world doesn't change we know that's
false it's changing every day there's
nothing we can do to stop it the
question that you have to ask on an
ongoing basis is is the world changing
in a way
that calls my results or my model into
question
so the only antidote
is to keep your eyes wide open
and you can also occasionally rebuild
your model refresh it using the most
recent data to help
inoculate yourself against this
gap number two
a lot of machine learning algorithms
take a lot of examples to learn
so
if i'm modeling something about internet
traffic say cyber security
i can
measure things i can collect data for a
day and get 100 million or a billion
examples i can train a sophisticated
machine learning model no problem
if
i am building a model of how corn grows
collecting one data point takes a year
so if i need thousands or tens of
thousands of data points
that's a problem
but by the time i get the answer you
know the problem that i was trying to
solve will be gone and i certainly won't
be around to worry about it
so
keeping in mind the time that it takes
to gather the data is important for some
of our applications for some of our
businesses don't worry there's an answer
to all this
and the third big gap
machine learning can't tell what caused
what
so here's a plot
it plots two different things
the number of pounds of cheese that on
average someone eats in a year over the
course of 10 years
and the number of people who died by
getting tangled up in their bed sheets
on each of those years
now we look at these and they track
pretty closely
i wouldn't be at all surprised to see
this in a magazine article
and the caption underneath
could read
excessive cheese consumption leads to
death by bed sheet strangulation
but what i want to point out and this is
this is a
subtle
but fundamental gap once you start
seeing it you won't be able to stop
seeing it
this graph doesn't say that at all
it's equally plausible to claim that
people dying by bed sheet strangulation
causes those around them to eat more
cheese
this doesn't actually suggest either one
of those
it just says hey they happened to move
in the same way over the same period
draw your own conclusions it would
require additional experimentation
to establish either one of those
causalities
so
this is big
i strongly urge you to keep an eye out
for this in
in the press
it's not always so benign
looking at our own business data we
might be able to see wow there was a
huge surge in profits profits in q4
of fy17
also
i took
many more business trips to belgium
during that period
so the obvious answer when using this to
make a decision i need to schedule more
business trips to belgium
we make decisions like this all the time
and and maybe they're right maybe
they're not but they're not data driven
the data does not tell us to make that
jump
okay so the three gaps
you have to collect a lot of data
machine learning assumes the world
doesn't change and it also doesn't tell
us anything about causality these are
gaps that keep us from being completely
data-driven from going from what our
data tells us
to the decisions we need to make
luckily to cross that gap we have our
human insight and judgment
we're really good at making reasonable
guesses with not enough data
in fact we're way too good at doing this
and we often have to rein it back and
use data to do that
but where the data stops
that's where we can let that go we can
follow our intuition our outside
experience our gut feeling
and cross that gap and make a decision
there's a paradox
this gap is caused by not enough data of
course if we had enough of exactly the
right data we could build these two
sides together so there would be no gap
whatsoever
in most cases
because
the world changes because data takes so
long to gather
because we get correlation and not
causation
that gap never gets fully closed
so we need to cross the gap to get more
information
but we can't close the gap until we get
more information
so we take the leap of intuition and
judgment and cross it for the first time
in the second time in the third time and
the more often we do that we use that
data to build it a little closer and a
little closer
over time the data we gather
often it'll tell us yes you know
what you guessed the answer should have
been that was exactly what it should
have been
sometimes it'll tell us oh that was
actually not the right way to go you
should have done this other thing
instead
but
it's better than standing on the far
side wishing for more data not being
able to do anything
so not being afraid to close that gap is
an important part of using our machine
learning results our data science
results
so we've completed our journey
conceptual journey through data science
i appreciate your patience i'm sure i've
raised many more questions than i've
answered
feel free
to contact me
there are a number of resources that
i'll share around in these slides
follow me on linkedin or twitter if
you'd like to get
links to the slides themselves this
video itself will be published in a
couple of days and keep an eye out for
that
and i thank you very much for your
patience we actually have a few minutes
left for questions and i will happily
stick around and feel those for the next
15 minutes
thank you
[Applause]
so
because this is being recorded if you
don't speak into a microphone
it didn't happen
there's a microphone there
and there's one right there i encourage
you to form a single file line behind
each one and we'll alternate if you have
any questions you'd like to ask
all right
maybe i did answer them all
okay we've got one right over here thank
you
um first of all um
excellent presentation to take a very
complex thing and make it
digestible is just
fabulous
um
my question is mostly about number four
check for quality
a lot of times the struggle with that is
how do you know as one person if
your results your data is has high
quality or low quality just kind of
looking for your input on that
in general
uh
so how do you know when it's of
sufficient quality there
there's obviously a lot
there's a lot of things you can do to
check a lot of it's domain specific so
what did what determines good data and
bad data determines on uh depends on the
problem that you're trying to solve and
what domain it is
i can give an example for instance i
worked in agriculture for a time
building models
and
it turns out that when you take
dig up some soil and go and process it
to measure the nitrogen in it
if you don't refrigerate that soil then
lots of chemical things happen by uh
bacteria go crazy and it changes the
levels of the nitrogen a lot
we got a whole bunch of data
and that data
we we learned about a third of it had
sat in a hot car trunk for a weekend
which of course throws those numbers off
entirely
and
so one way to handle that would be to
say okay that data is suspect we just
don't trust it we're going to remove it
unfortunately we didn't have any way of
knowing of all of our data points which
third that was
so
that's that's a pretty extreme example
of raising serious questions about data
quality and at that point
you know we actually decided to
backtrack and try something else
entirely but it was completely dependent
on
the domain that we were in knowing
things about biology and
about soil that i didn't know before
and
also it depended on the answers that we
were trying to get out of it
one thing that i've learned is that real
world data
painfully enough every single data point
actually has a story behind it
you wouldn't want that to be the case
you want it to be clean and reproducible
and perfect and mean exactly the same
thing every time
but
sensors fail networks fail
bad things just happen
and so sometimes determining whether
data is good or bad is a discipline all
in itself
thanks we'll take this one next
yes i'd like to go back to your point
about closing the gap and i guess the
question i have is
there's an old adage people don't allow
data to stand in the way of their
opinions so
how do you close that gap with people
who really are not interested in getting
into the back of what's going on here
and really do want to believe that
eating cheese causes strangulation
what's your views on how you can
actually close that without just opening
the book and say well there's the stats
i love that
that question there's obviously a
a spectrum
on one side of the spectrum we have
i will not do or believe anything until
it's incontrovertibly supported by data
anyone at that end of the spectrum
doesn't do or believe anything
on the other end of the spectrum is
i will do and believe what i like
regardless of what data i observe
so data has no effect there and you know
we all fall somewhere in between so the
question is as i understand it like well
how do you if you're interacting with
people that are leaning this direction
how do you convince them how do you
change their mind
if i if i knew the answer to that i
would i'd be a very wealthy man
but it's an important question to
consider it probably depends entirely on
the individual that you're interacting
with
it's a very unsatisfying answer but it's
an excellent question thanks
hi so i'll just thank you i'll uh echo
previous sentiments this was a really
fantastic talk and thank you so much uh
this question i think really piggybacks
on the last one which is
what advice would you have for
sort of
best practices for generating good
hypotheses and having you know sort of
appropriate senses of skepticism around
the data
or around the sort of models that you're
building so that you can you know
avoid these kind of cheese strangulation
you know mistakes
uh
yeah so so this is a good thing that
i've a big thing that i've been
faced with quite a few times
one thing that i've learned
is to never
trust my data
i take what's there at face value but i
don't ever assume that it's absolutely
correct so when a question comes up
something's unusual one of the possible
answers is
there's a flaw in the data
the other
trick
is to never trust my model
so whenever a question comes up it's not
behaving the way i would expect it to
the other possibility i look at is maybe
there's something funny
going on with my model
and
coming at it from a continually being
skeptical of it
helps me often to find that i've done
something wrong which is the case more
often than not
to look for errors try to anticipate
errors try to
create errors in what i've done and try
to break it and when i've tried
unsuccessfully to break it or fix it
then
i you know draw what i feel like might
be an unlikely or counterintuitive
suggestion that
the you know cheese causes bed sheet
strangulation
one big red flag
is when my data
firmly and
soundly supports something that i
already believed and really want to
believe
there's a strong tendency to have
confirmation bias
and to stop when you get the answer
you're looking for
and the only way i know to inoculate
yourself against that is to
distrust your own beliefs a little bit
too and just be pretty ruthless in how
hard you beat on
so yes
uh again to echo thank you for an
outstanding presentation today and i
don't so much of a question as a as a
thought to throw out to the gentleman
who just asked about changing minds um
and this is where the science in data
science comes in this is where you have
to approach your work without
preconception get rid of those a priori
notions and approach it with an open
mind because if you don't approach this
objectively you are creating an echo
chamber you're not doing science you're
not doing predictive analytics and this
bears itself out through models because
you'll create a confirmation bias but
that will quickly be disproven when a
real data comes to play why is our model
wrong
you guys just you stopped when you got
that answer so what you said there i
think exactly answered what this
gentleman's question was but thank you
again for outstanding talk thank you
it's a it's a really important thing
one thing that has surprised me as i've
come to understand it is how
bad scientists can be at doing science
in the sense of approaching things
skeptically of being willing to disprove
their own hypotheses there's quite a few
examples of popular ideas that have
stayed popular for a long time despite
a big pile of
data adequate to convince an open-minded
observer otherwise
so
another ego here great presentation
um my questions are
a bit more specific about technologies
you showed a
slide there with a lot of cloud-based
solutions for tools
um
on-premise tools still valid to do this
data science and data cleansing light
like a sql server data quality
and uh master data service before you
get the data to the cloud or is the
tendency to do all the data cleansing in
the clouds
oh yes
so
personally i use a mixture of tools
on premise versus cloud i find doesn't
affect my ability to
take this journey around the circle that
i've showed
but some applications are more suited to
one than the other it usually depends
what you're trying to do
sometimes the data is so large that it
just doesn't fit on my laptop in which
case cloud's a great way to go or if i
want to share it with a lot of people i
want to build say my model and create a
web service so that a thousand or a
million different people can query it
and use it then cloud is an obvious
winner there and
also
i mean
outright plug here microsoft has done a
lot of work to make these cloud tools
actually very intuitive to use and so
sometimes just for pure ease of use it's
just convenient to open a browser and
pull up azure machine learning and put
together a model right there all right
thanks
thanks
hi
my question is around
how much do you find yourself trying to
learn about the domain to which the data
applies for example
you talked about diamonds so if you
don't know there's something called
clarity or inclusions then you i would
expect you wouldn't be as effective at
it if you're analyzing dropped calls for
example on a cell phone
and you don't know there's different
like something about towers and
something about which model tone you
have which waves it's using
as a scientist
what's your assessment of how much time
you should
be spending learning and becoming an
expert maybe or not becoming an expert
at the subject matter that you're
analyzing
in my experience every
every amount of time that i've been
willing to invest in learning domain has
paid off in the quality of the results
machine learning algorithms are there's
a
tool box of them that are fairly common
and it's actually there are a few
people who have taken a shot at you know
automatically take your data set and
just run every single one of these on
them and find the one that works the
best
usually for a lot of common business
problems that's not the hard part the
hard part is cleaning your data in a
smart way
for instance when i have missing values
what do i do with that do i substitute
in a 0 do i substitute in some estimate
do i remove that person entirely
the right answer for that will depend a
lot on the data and exactly what it
means
and
i have found that
if i try to just take the data as a
table of numbers and names and and put
it black box into a an algorithm
it it never works i always end up having
to backtrack
i study up what does this mean what does
this mean i talk to people and usually
even the ones i thought i understand i
realized that i was interpreting them
wrong
or even if i interpreted it according to
the label i learned that the label was
wrong so
being willing to get and just dive into
your data set and get your hands really
dirty pays off 10 times over
thank you
hi
thanks for the great talk i can actually
hope go home and sleep properly thinking
that i can also do data science it's not
as dumb excellent
my question was regarding um your data
science process in your first few slides
you mentioned
certain categories or techniques
of algorithms the first one was basic
classification
yes or no true or false
and about your fourth
technique where you mentioned if it's
almost like an anomaly whether it's this
weird or not
the answer to that is also like an yes
or no so how is that different from the
first classification how is that
technique and how do we identify it
so it's a really good point you know
it's it could be
you could see it as a two class
classification is this weird or is this
not and that's actually how it's
implemented in some cases not in all
what i presented of course was a
a very high level simplification
there are other types of machine
learning algorithms there but that's
kind of like the broad swath down main
street of of capturing most of them but
with anomaly detection algorithms some
of them are two-class classification
the
reason that that becomes challenging is
that two class classification algorithms
usually assumes about equal numbers of
of yes's and no's of of haves and
have-nots
by nature
anomaly detection you don't have very
many they're anomalous they're weird and
usually
you're looking not only for weird things
that you've seen before but you're even
more interested in weird things that you
haven't seen before so it's a slightly
different type of problem so even when
you do use two class classification
methods you have to tweak them a little
bit to solve it but good good insight
into that relationship thank you
so there's no one over here so we'll
take the next one right here and just a
heads up we just have one more minute
and then we'll have to wrap up hi thanks
for the great talk i i have a question
in one of the first slides you said that
the machine learning
process and the data science process
assumes that the world doesn't change
but the world changes can you maybe give
an example of where
it's hard to solve a problem because the
things change so much and maybe it's not
enough just to put new data in and like
retrain your things you know what do you
do in those situations like if you can
give an example and what tools microsoft
has you know to deal with that
yes um
so two-part question we're just about
out of time but a very brief answer
is anything having to deal with your
customers if you have a business so the
what you learn about your customers when
your company is small may not apply six
months later if your company's doubled
in size so something very important to
keep an eye on at that point
i apologize that i don't have time to
dig deeper because it's a very
insightful question but thank you very
much and thank you all very much for
your attention
[Applause]